cual es la relacion de cambio promedio jec
sobre el trabajo de equipos más grandes que
menos cinco en menos que - en total
obtienen equipos más pequeños - cinco en sombras
de acceso igual a 6
y cuando los equipos escolares - jec ses
igual a cero
para saber el tipo de cambio
prometió el tipo de cambio prometió cgd
equipos con respeto y podemos asumir
que esta contra el espectro aix
Estoy siendo e intercambiando vg en este
rango terminado e intercambio de equipo terminado
este rango de símbolos para el tipo de cambio es
este triangulo de escritura y que puede
escribe desde según equipos de
intercambio en el onnix intercambio hacer en
tipo de cambio promedio en este rango
mientras cambiasso y en este intervalo de
6 a 0
podemos ver esto como un punto final en
sombras
este es el final y este comienzo de otro
manera
podríamos tener un resultado consistente
como estos es grande la lista al principio
esto sera el principio y luego china
pensamos en 6 y terminamos tercero a
ser menos seis disminuido 6 es -6
podríamos exigir que el tipo de cambio sea 15 - 5
- incrementarlos en 36 cuando queramos
simplificar resaltado - 6 sobre 35 a
menos los tonos
mostró el sonido de intercambio promedio de jack
en intervalo con de equipos mayores a
menos 5 y mejoramos el esse -os en
tesis cada vez en significa que y que si
incremento un día dice punto de mira en dos